what we got here guys what have we got
hi I'm Justine and this is a big box
we're about to open it and you tell by
the box that says the way traveled up
home so I wonder what that could be
I'm not sure I had this for a little
while and I've been anticipating the
unboxing of it well head out on a trip
so I decided that I think this is the
time that I should probably open up 2013
this is an extremely special suitcase
they cannot only visitation but it will
also charge any of your devices via USB
this is the biggest multi charger you'll
ever see great packaging the whole
entire box is frankly better than
airplane wing time rustles you know my
dad is looking at me like that's
something I can eat so when I travel I
basically bring everything that I think
that I potentially might need every time
I go somewhere I don't bring the thing
that I said I'm not going to need this I
need it so suitcases travel gear luggage
all of that just is something that I'm
very very interested in anything does
make my life easier traveling with a dog
traveling with computers and drones it
allows oh wow that's good real life here
it is also I would like to note that
since I went and traveled to Europe last
year and I basically made it three
almost four weeks entirely packing
everything that I needed an Akari on
that's in my hole I do not like to check
bag I never really like to check bag
sometimes you have to so let's take a
look at this suitcase I have been
wanting this for quite a long time ever
since I first saw it it's got a nice
little luggage tag here which is also
very important because if you ever lose
your things
I'm just serving how much room I'm going
to take up for all of my items because I
pick up a lot of really this is nice
this is nice
we've got these little straps which are
also extremely important when I'm
packing is I like to make sure
especially if I have electronics I want
them to be tied down inside of here
so one of the things that I usually run
into is a huge issue is these little
things the handle bar comes up in so
trying to strategically pack around
those tends to be probably one of the
most difficult things that I run into
when I'm backing so I like to use simple
for those electronics or even just
clothing I like getting different types
of like packing squares things that are
small that will fit and Clyde it there
so that basically when you're packing
it's kind of like you're building the
Lego set you want everything to fit
super super snug to the de-rating face
and nothing goes around I think is
Pinkus how am i charged it how does it
work
it looks like there's pretty ample room
I also really like this little thing
this kind of would just sit right on top
of your stuff if you could add like some
extra little things I've never had
luggage that had this sort of little
addition to it well in here
it was a nice little micro USB cable and
also a nice little adapter so you can
charge your suitcase so what about if
you know your bag inside and out what
did I throw what's that
it says here that if a TSA have
questions about battery that's what this
little screwdriver is course I guess
that means always keep this with you the
battery power in this is 10,000
milliamps which is capable of charging
an iphone up to five times if at any
time in the first hundred days you feel
like it's not working out you could
return it for a full refund no questions
oh that's incredible and there's a
lifetime warranty like I'm not making
this up it says it right here let's take
a look at the most important part of
this bag this bag comes in several other
colors and also several other sizes but
for me I wanted something that I could
have as a carry-on because most the time
that have been need a charge in my phone
I'd like to have my suitcase with me
let's get into it guys let's take this
set up is not adequate for what I'm
doing right now but we're going to make
it work so that's what we do this is a
wall I'm up against this just flips
right down like that and then you can
charge one of them is one in and the
other one two point one and so depending
upon if you need a faster charge you
would use the blue one and right here is
your little LED lights and you can see
if it's charging so I'm going to plug it
in and see if we can get a good charge
going just pull it in right here and
it's lighting up to show me that this
baby is charging it feels incredibly
sturdy which is something that is very
very important if you're traveling and
with a lifetime warranty that is
something that is also extremely
important because I've gone through a
lot of luggage a lot of luggage that has
seen better days
love same vanity
there's a see away luggage uh paddling
the description where guys can check
this out on a huge thank you to them for
actually sending me this because I said
that Bini realizes he can have any
review unit so just kind of want to like
check it out and see if it's for me and
guess what
it definitely is yeah let's cut you a
nice slo-mo montage of the suitcase whoo
[Music]
you
alright guys well that's it this is the
away suitcase once again let me know
what you guys think of this and if you
have any other cool travel tips or
travel gear that you think that would
definitely make my life easier leave me
those in the comments below or feel free
to send me a tweet because I feel like
I'm always on Twitter like 24/7 if I'm
not eating I'm just reading tweet yeah
I'll see you guys later
[Music]